house of the dragon is full of new faces
and not all of them used to belong to
the doctor here's where else you've seen
the talented cast
someone must always sit on the iron
throne and at the start of house of the
dragon that responsibility falls to king
viserys targaryen played by veteran
actor patty considine king viserys is
described in hbo's official promotions
for the series as a good man setting him
miles apart from the game of thrones
character who later bears his name
outside of westeros considine has had a
long and varied career in both film and
television a versatile and lauded
performer he's equally well known for
indie films like dead man's shoes and in
america and big budget blockbusters like
the born ultimatum
i can't think
we can't laugh i can't cry
i can't
he's also collaborated with simon pegg
and nick frost on hot fuzz and the
world's end considine's other major tv
roles include claude bolton in the
stephen king adaptation the outsider and
the despicable father john hughes in the
british crime saga peaky blinders
though the targaryens are at the center
of house of the dragon they're far from
the only great house in westeros with a
stake in the game one of the other major
players is house hightower a family that
doesn't play an especially major role in
game of thrones but which has a long and
storied history on the continent one of
the main characters in house of the
dragon is alison hightower daughter of
sir otto hightower the hand of the king
teenage allison is played by newcomer
emily carey alison hightower is brought
to life as an adult by english actor
olivia cook a young star who's
nonetheless accrued a lot of notable
credits in her career
reuben you hurt yourself
you hurt me
i'll hurt myself too i'll hurt myself
too
cook first rose to prominence starring
in a couple of bbc miniseries including
the secret of prickly hall alongside
game of thrones star maisie williams
she's also applied her trade in the
alfred hitchcock inspired series bates
motel and the itv historical drama
vanity fair on the big screen cook has
appeared in films like sound of metal
and steven spielberg's ready player one
what would a song of ice and fire be
without a few cool enigmatic rogue
warrior types that's the archetype that
lord corliss velardian falls into in
house of the dragon though you'd be
wrong to write him off as simply a trope
viewed in his day as the best sea
captain in all of westeros cordless
hails from a family nearly as
prestigious as house targaryen a key
part of the royal court and a respected
ruler in his own right the sea snake
isn't a man to be trifled with
four ships have now been lost the last
one was flying my banner you might not
immediately recognize the name steve
toussaint but you've almost certainly
seen him in something the hollywood
veteran has had a long career with
credits that range from genre affair
like prince of persia the sands of time
to serious dramas on the stage and
screen toussaint is most prolific on
television though with roles in the noc
inspector lewis and netflix's pine gap
at the center of the drama in house of
the dragon is prince daemon targaryen
played by british star matt smith the
younger brother of king viserys and
uncle to princess rhaenyra damon is a
dragon rider warrior and all-around
major player in the politics of
continent a complicated figure to say
the least he played a major role in the
dance of the dragons and the preceding
political turmoil in part because of his
own desire for power most fans of sci-fi
and fantasy television will instantly
recognize smith as the 11th doctor in
doctor who a role he played for three
seasons from 2010 to 2013 and for which
he gained widespread acclaim a very
skinny
that is proper skinny i've never seen it
from the outside fans of historical
dramas may know smith better for his
role as prince philip in netflix's the
crown a performance that earned him a
primetime emmy nomination in 2018. on
the big screen smith is known for roles
like jack in edgar wright's last night
in soho alex and terminator genesis and
the villainous milo in morbius
the main action of house of the dragon
proceeds and involves the dance of the
dragons a civil war of sorts fought
between different targaryen claimants to
the iron throne one of those claimants
is princess rhaenyra targaryen played as
an adult by emma darcy an actor equally
at home on the stage and the screen
darcy started out in various live
theater productions in the uk before
landing some tv and film roles darcy
appeared in the 2020 british comedy
misbehavior the bbc drama baptist and
the itv comedy drama wild bill just to
name a few roles the role of rhaenyra in
house of the dragon is undoubtedly
darcy's highest profile role to date one
shared by australian newcomer millie
alcock who plays the princess as a 15
year old
every game of thrones fan knows what an
important and often dangerous position
the hand of the king is in westeros
depending on the current monarch of the
land the hand may wind up being the true
ruler behind the scenes like his father
before him king viserys targaryen relies
on otto hightower as his hand played in
house of the dragon by rhys evans a
long-standing member of the royal court
and a man of nearly impeccable
reputation otto is also the father of
allison hightower a role that ends up
pulling him even further into the messy
family politics of the targaryens a
welsh actor and longtime star of the
screen evans is probably best known for
his roles in notting hill come on open
up
this is me
spikey the harry potter franchise and as
dr kurt connors aka the lizard in the
amazing spider-man evens has also had a
number of prominent television roles
including playing sherlock holmes older
brother mycroft in the cbs crime
procedural elementary
dragon rider overlooked air and wife to
the sea snake cordless velaryon princess
rhaenys targaryen occupies a unique role
in the royal court of westeros rhaenys
carries the less than proud nickname of
the queen who never was a reference to
her being passed up as successor to king
joharis targaryen the first in favor of
her cousin paserus being denied the iron
throne does little to curb princess
rhaenys's influence and drive however
and she forms a fearsome couple with her
seafaring husband raynese is played by
tv stalwart eve best in house of the
dragon best is probably most
recognizable for her long-standing role
as dr eleanor o'hara in nurse jackie and
for her supporting performance as
wallace simpson in the king's speech
more recently she appeared in the bbc
miniseries the honorable woman and
netflix's teen fantasy show fate the
wink saga
initially an outsider in the court of
king viserys targaryen rosaria isn't
even a native of westeros and yet she
eventually rises to become what hbo
calls the most trusted and most unlikely
ally of prince damon targaryen visaria
is brought to life by sonoya mizuno an
actor arguably known best for her many
collaborations with sci-fi autur alex
garland mizuno has featured in several
of garland's projects including ex
machina and the cosmic horror
masterpiece annihilation her other film
credits include crazy rich asians beauty
and the beast and la la land
neither a lord nor a ruler sir kristen
cole might seem at first like the odd
man out in the main cast of house of the
dragon being common born he's not
exactly overflowing with riches or power
but he manages to defeat daemon
targaryen in combat in the premiere
episode and make a strong impression on
princess rhaenyra just as kristin cole
is a bit of an unknown quantity in house
of the dragon so too is the actor fabian
frankel the least established star in
the main cast a graduate of the royal
academy of dramatic art and the london
academy of music and dramatic art
frankel got his big break in the bbc one
mini-series the serpent which tells the
terrifying real-life story of a french
serial killer he also appeared in the
2019 romantic comedy last christmas
alongside game of thrones star emilia
clark
where would a king of westeros be
without his kingsguard the white-cloaked
guardians of the royal family have
always played a key role in a song of
ice and fire and that tradition
continues in house of the dragon as lord
commander of the kingsguard during the
reign of king viserys targaryen sir
harold westerling has a lot on his plate
house of the dragon sets him in a
tumultuous time for the family he's
sworn to protect but he carries himself
with dignity and professionalism
nonetheless fans of the fantasy genre
should be well acquainted with grier
mctavish the actor responsible for
embodying sir harold in house of the
dragon he appears in all three of peter
jackson's the hobbit films as well as
the star's time travel fantasy epic
outlander
it's fiction
outlandish fiction just as comfortable
in a voice booth mctavish has lent his
vocal talents to a number of video games
and animated series and films including
dracula in netflix's critically
acclaimed castlevania series that all
barely even scratches the surface of
mctavish's career which also includes
credits like the saint of killers and
preacher among many other smaller roles
while the family may not be too
important during the events of game of
thrones one particular member of house
beesbury lord lyman plays a key role in
house of the dragon as an ally of the
high towers and the master of coin on
king viserys small council this
otherwise unassuming man holds a
substantial amount of influence in the
realm at the start of the show who
better to portray an unassuming belord
than experienced character actor bill
patterson the scott is best known in
recent times for playing phoebe
wallerbridge's father in fleabag of
every star on this list patterson may
have the longest resume as his on-screen
career stretches all the way back to the
early 1970s
as such he's been a mainstay of british
tv for decades including a brief feature
on doctor who in 2010 alongside his
house of the dragon co-star matt smith